what tell a story of my first race
weekend but how the heck did I get here
start with motorcycles on the street
then I got into tractors sold my last
motorcycle track day we're all gridded
up we're delayed getting out on track
for some reason and then we find out the
reason for the delay is they're actually
still trying to find someone's finger
who lost it on track so that was my last
motorcycle track day and I got into cars
so then I got the s2000 and found cars
to be just as much fun except for when
they were letting you down a lot so then
I got the 911 made it pretty and took it
to the track so a December 2018 the
opportunity to race presented itself and
you don't have to ask me twice to race
you're gonna need a racing license for
that you're gonna need a decently
substantial track history check past
medical check and get signed off by a
CDI chief driving instructor next you're
gonna need year a lot of gear next you
need to race car you're gonna need a
crew you might think he'll I don't
really need a crew but try doing a pit
stop all by yourself you know try
managing that car managing your
hydration and racing hard of those three
things you can pick 1.5 so the crew the
car the tires especially like pry your
biggest expense over the entire weekend
is actually just going to be in tires
all that stuff's really expensive and
just out of the range for most people
including myself so having the
opportunity to do something like this
was just just incredible so anyway with
all that stuff I'm ready to race but am
I ready to race so you know leading up
to going to actually race the you know a
lot of questions come into your mind and
then even people on the outside start
kind of offering some doubt for you I
mean most people were super supportive
but there were definitely some people
who were like I can't believe you're
gonna go race you're just gonna get
destroyed you're gonna be a rolling
chicane you know just like super slow
and just in everybody's way that kind of
stuff and you know it kind of makes you
think and like boom is this really
something I should be doing but every
time I talk to somebody who is like an
actual racecar driver so like all the
people who were like questioning or
there were all the same in one regard
and that was they had never raced yes so
what did they know
where does like all the racers
themselves all of them were like
unanimously like yeah get out here you
know like they just they want you to be
a part of it so anyway I ended up just
going ahead and doing it so the race
weekend is here Thursday as an
orientation for the newbies like me and
then Friday is a testing and practice
day which is kind of like a typical
track day except it's kind of like
racing rules applies so there's passing
anywhere without a point and this was my
first time experiencing that and it was
really liberating and it's cool because
the responsibility to get by the person
is now on you rather than on them to
like let you by and so that was really
cool and it was just cool to be around a
lot of people who were really good
drivers like I had a typical de you can
trust like 10% where as head at a race
weekend you can trust like 90% of the
drivers so Saturday comes around and
it's qualifying for the first race you
know my goal for this entire weekend was
really just one thing and that is finish
like don't get disqualified don't get it
did not finish because I watered up the
car into a wall or I collected someone
else or someone else collected me all
right time for the first race somehow I
managed to qualify second in class don't
know how that happened in first in
classes that white came in up until the
left number 90 so here we're in a
rolling start sort of grid formation
waiting for the green any second now
boom there's the green you can't see it
in the video but we'll pass the green
flag here any second
yeah right there to the left so it's a
race for turn one yeah you know I just
wanted to finish but when that flag goes
green and everybody around you is like
racing and driving hard you have a
couple of choices you can you can either
drive pretty aggressively and hopefully
hold position you can drive overly
aggressively and probably crash into
somebody or you can dial it back a
little bit and you're just gonna get
stomped on sure so so this was like the
first experience of that for me where
it's like oh my gosh this is racing
like you just you know you watch it on
TV and it looks pretty graceful but
until you're actually in the car and you
do it for yourself you you just can't
respect how chaotic it is especially at
the beginning of the race just insane
but immediately I'm hooked I mean the
mental challenge here is so high you're
trying to process so many variables and
you have a set amount of time right you
don't have that enough time to process
everything so anyway incredible
so as the race goes on things kind of
start to settle down people find their
groove and groups kind of start to form
and separate from each other
and I find myself catching up to this
group of four other cars and I really
need to get by this guy because I'm the
caboose and five cars got a lot of work
ahead of me and if this group kind of
starts to really come together and get
closer to each other like they are ahead
it's gonna be really hard so I make the
attempt on this turn one here and I just
kind of back out clearly I don't have it
you can even tell in the video a lot of
times in the video it's hard to see
what's going on Bob beside me but
clearly he had the turn so the rules are
whoever is ahead at turn in kind of has
the turn so if you're not ahead at turn
in you can't really go for it mean you
can but if there's an incident like
someone hits somebody it's your fault
so anyways another lap later I'm coming
up behind this guy I know he's gonna try
too late break me again so I've got it
down I could make the move for it I
definitely have it you can't even see
him in the video so yeah it's over for
him
and you could tell he's unhappy I had to
like basically park it and turn one but
it was that's okay it's my turn
so now there's lots of space between the
cars ahead got to catch them pass them
okay so now I need to figure out how I'm
gonna pass these next three cars but as
you can see that guy is still behind me
poking his nose in everywhere so I've
got kind of drive a little defensively
it's taking away a lot of my options
here so come around here he pokes his
nose in and I just can't believe it he's
going for this turn I think he cut the
track cheated a little bit but dang it
I'm looking loose again so here we go
we're coming up to turn 11 and the one
thing that's really nice about these
came in club sports is the braking so
you can outbreak pretty much everybody
here so I decide that's what I'm gonna
do to this guy I'm just gonna outbreak
him coming into 11 sure enough break it
pucker
we're good we basically parked it at
turn 11 but we made it awesome so now I
start to notice that this guy in front
of me he's like under steering
everywhere and even sees correcting and
this car just doesn't seem secure so my
plan is to pass him right here is I'm
confident he'll just keep under steering
sure enough passed him threaded that
needle nicely that 997 is like well but
anyway
made it awesome and we're off so cool by
the way if you guys are not enjoying the
narration I'm going to post all of the
races in the description so if you just
want to watch them in all their glory
you can
so anyways coming through turn nineteen
screwed up a little bit I'm trying to
take a defensive line here this guy's
about to pass me but I can just squeeze
him out just enough all set great but
then as you can see he is he's gaining
on me pretty slowly but it's gaining on
me nonetheless he's definitely drafting
me he's definitely gonna go to pass me
here
and sure enough he goes for it I have to
give it to him he definitely got it so
I've got to take a wide turn slow turn
through here kind of slows me down he's
going slow because he just took the pass
and the other guy goes for it as well so
now I'm side by side with him and he's
slowly
Erick's it out and dang it I'm the
frickin caboose again haha so now we're
coming through a noun like god I like
reassess all over again how do I get by
these people so one of the things that's
cool is like as the as things change
over time like and as you pass people
they remember how you passed them so
we're coming up to turn 11 again and I'm
thinking of trying to pass that blue and
green came and again just doing the
exact same thing I just did to him
because I can out break him through that
turn so we're coming up and I'm just
trying to check his body language but
he's kind of over a little bit and so
I'm thinking he's gonna go for it and
then he does but it's definitely two
ladies oh he hits that nine nine seven
and the cool thing is a couple of things
first of all there were reflexes on that
997 freaking incredible either first of
all also second of all they're back on
track they're still racing they just hit
each other but they're still in the race
and the only reason they're pulling back
a little bit there is because that came
in is giving way to the 997 because they
just punted him so so anyway just
incredible also that 997 his reflexes he
just before they hit he swerves and I
think that's the only reason both of
them are still driving right now
they don't want suspension issues so
just really cool and yet again I'm
behind the same came and he's under
steering
again we're coming to the same spot I'm
thinking maybe I'll try to pass him here
but he blocks it so again it's just so
cool because you can tell people they
remember it is like nope not again so
I'm like dang now how am I gonna get by
this guy so we're coming through
carousel and again he's like he's
clearly under steering and so I'm like
I'm just not sure if I should try to
pass him even like on the outside or
something and then boom I get by him
through the carousel and he just like
let me by I'm pretty sure and then you
can see here he just pits so I don't
know if he was having issues or what but
anyway whatever is now me in this 996 I
don't know if this is like a cup car a
Carrera S I just don't know anyways
we're coming down this few laps later
coming down a straight leg approach this
came in and I recognize this cam and
this is a Cayman that's pretty slow and
as traffic comes they drive off line
always so so I know this 996 doesn't
seem to know this so I get by and it
everything's going good but I'm actually
side by side with this 996 right now you
can't see all that another pokin out and
I'm like dang it but then we come
through here and I'm like well Ivan
pulled this trick on the 996 so I do it
in finally I am by this guy the relief
so now at this point there's literally
no one else in sight we've been held up
for too long the race is too close to
the end so this is it I just kind of
make sure he's not gaining on me and no
one else is gaining on me and this is
just the end of the race
so in the race I finished second in
class because there's like a million
classes of cars so I finished second in
class and then improved my positions in
six places overall from qualifying so
that was actually really cool and then I
just like learned a lot about racing
because it's really nothing can prepare
you for like a real race so I did
practice race starts and we you know
obviously there's qualifying where
people were trying their hardest to get
fast laps and there was the whole day of
Friday that was like practice days but
everybody drives way different who when
it's a real race and the flag goes green
and you know what hits the fan so learn
a lot about all that and then also just
realizing oh my gosh like how much more
mentally challenging racing is as
opposed to just track driving I mean
you're trying to manage like six cars in
front of you and watch for three at
least three cars behind you you're
trying to find those holes and predict
there's like some sort of gaps gonna
occur but you also have to predict what
all those other cars are gonna do so
that's like just the most mentally
demanding thing I've ever had to do you
know I've worked out some really hard
problems in my time but it's the
difference in racing is like you have a
set a fixed period of time that's like
really short to process a huge number of
variables so yeah awesome just really
cool all right so about an hour later
it's time for race - I'm starting in p3
but position 2 3 & 4 are actually pretty
close in qualifying times so we're
actually really close to each other at
the start position one is Nicole she's
somewhere miles up ahead she's better
than ever
sorry so so we're not really competing
against Nicole yet so now the flag goes
green I'm trying to go into the inside
but then it gets blocked so kind of
screwed here you can see in the rearview
that came in with the bright orange kind
of window visor thing that's position
four and then the orange came in his
position the other guy basically you
can't see him here I'll point them out
as soon as you can see him but really
quickly in this race we're all three
really tight-knit it's just an
incredible battle initially you can see
a number so the orange came in in that
rear video for a second there that's the
other guy and then the guy right to my
right right now
that's position two three four it varies
throughout the race actually I don't
think he was ever in fourth but anyways
we are like side by side right now you
can't see him but he's forcing me to
take a look alive the line here so
coming through here just trying to do
whatever I can to make some separation
between me and these two other guys in
my class
[Music]
so coming around here I'm kind of
screwed I'm pretty sure I'm still yeah
so I'm side-by-side with that guy so
right there right behind me with that
bright orange reddish thing that's now
now I'm in p2 he's mp3 and the orange
came in is before so coming through here
I'm trying to pass that gray came and
it's just not happening he goes wait he
goes wider than I thought he was gonna
go so he definitely has me there so
we're coming down here if I recall right
off to my right yeah there he is
so that's gorge number 744 so he's
definitely got me here but I'm looking
up ahead I'm just praying that the
caiman in front of me doesn't under
break and I can definitely pass him
because that guy has no options so I go
ahead and make the pass here I basically
have to park it through this turn but
good I've made it but he's actually
still off to my right I can't see him
but he's there so now I've got to like
turn it away here I'm coming around
coming around I'm fighting this guy I'm
fighting this guy I'm fighting this guy
he's by me so now I'm in trouble now I'm
back to p3
dang it p4 is right behind me this is a
crazy battle coming through here I'm
trying to pass number 744 I can't quite
get it done though and there he still is
and now I'm getting pushed wide by I
believe it's the spec 997 we'll see here
in a second but I'm just in trouble you
definitely don't want to be in the paint
the grip sucks and yeah you can sort of
see the guy there we'll see what happens
coming up to this turn
there he is so now I'm in p3 p4 is
literally right behind me there and yeah
so then he p4 tries to make the move and
I'm like you know squeezed him out and
that's like a perfect example of the
aggression that you've got to have it's
like this perfect balance that you've
got to strike where he wants to be
aggressive enough to try to take that
pass but for me I have to be aggressive
enough to say no and trust that he's
gonna not be too aggressive so then up
ahead we got a yellow flag someone has
spun out here hopefully everybody knows
and doesn't try to pass me we get by
that no problem can you imagine how
scary it would be to be that car like as
people are kind of the hill they can't
see you you can't see them but they're
coming fast it's tight brake zone what
if someone blows it freaking scary so
some time goes by battling for position
to again you can see the orange came in
in the rear view camera there but
they've kind of dropped back so they're
not really in contention anymore so now
it's me and this other guy fighting for
p2
so we're coming up I can't really decide
should I try to pass this guy in the
turn 11 coming up you see me do a couple
of passes there but he's kind of holding
a defensive line so I'm just not sure
what his plan is there then he pops over
like he's gonna pass I have no idea it
was way too late but now he screwed
himself for this turn I go wide I get a
nice run up on him
and I'm already on him and then I go to
pass him I just shouldn't have done that
that was like my main issue for like the
entire weekend like in a de and track
days you really don't hug behind
somebody because you can't trust that
they're gonna have smart break zones so
I have this habit of popping out I
should have drafted him for way longer
and then popped out at the end but if I
had done that that guy that just tried
to pass me there or thought about
passing me who would have blocked me and
then I would have been screwed but
anyway that the set number 744 the guy
I'm fighting right now he's actually
right to my right he's there this whole
time I wish I had a side camera but
there he is there he's still there he's
still there I'm trying to hold the
inside because I can't just drive into
he's still there and I'm finally by that
guy that took forever now I am p2 feels
good so where's p1 well time for the
easiest position one
ever we've got a yellow flag going here
I go
coming through turn 20 there's p1 off to
the right there I pull she had a
mechanical sucks I didn't want to get p1
that way but I got a trophy for that
race so day three comes we have a
60-minute enduro to put this in
perspective the other like sprint races
were like 22 to 25 minutes or something
like that a 60 minute enduro is a long
time to be behind the wheel there is a
five minute required pit stop somewhere
in there like you can do it anywhere
between the first 15 after the first 15
minutes and I think before the last 10
minutes but you kind of do a little bit
of strategizing there and I'll talk
about that in a second but first of all
we weren't even sure if we were gonna
make it so even though there's a pit
stop required you could not fuel so you
were not allowed to fuel in the pit stop
really weird so anyway we're worried
that we're not even gonna make it in the
fuel numbers like we've crunched the
numbers like 25 times and it was always
gonna be really close so that was a
problem and then also just in the
warm-up that morning and qualifying that
morning we were having overheating
issues with the car and that was
occurring after like 10 minutes so we
weren't really sure we're gonna make it
the engineers again like I said before
super useful they did what they could
with some heat shielding but we really
weren't sure are we going to be able to
make this or not finally my number one
competition for the enduro was gonna do
a driver change after we knew like the
first 15 minutes and he was gonna change
to a driver that was way faster than me
so I'm much better than me so all these
things came together and was like man I
was so sure that there's no way we could
win that enduro so day 3 is here and now
it's time for a 60 minute enduro so I
qualified in second in class again in
that orange came in too
the up ahead and to the right is my
competition to pass so this is the start
you've seen the starts before you know
how crazy they are obviously I'm just
monitoring where he's at and you can see
all those cars kind of bunched up to the
right so I'm pretty confident I can even
just get by him after turn one and it's
a central I get by him because me and
him are about the exact same pace but
after 15 minutes we already know there's
going to be a driver change and there we
go I have passed him here
anyway after 15 minutes we already know
and someone just tries to push me off
track there we already know they're
gonna change into a much faster driver
like someone who's 3 seconds a lap
faster than me and that's huge so now
it's just a function of trying to make
the gap between me and him as large as
possible for his son hops in the car and
catches all backup to me and also
basically as soon as he hits we're gonna
try to pit that way we can kind of
minimize some of the variables so once
we've hit a full course yellow comes out
while we're in the pit and in racing
that's like a seriously good stroke of
luck because because that means everyone
else is on track like while you're in
pit doing nothing everyone else is on
track having to drive much slower
whereas like while other people pit I
was driving on track at full speed
including my competition in that orange
came in so after driving around slow for
a while with the full course yellow
we're about to go back to the green flag
but we're not in like that grid
formation we're in like single-file so
like when that flag does green I can't
even see it so thankfully we're on a
radio with the engineer who calls it
when the flag goes green so it's green
and already some people have spun gone
off and they're just as usual starts and
restarts are always super super hectic
but at least right now I don't see that
orange came in so I've got a pretty good
gap on him so far
but eventually he shows up so yeah five
minutes later there's Russell on my tail
and I know if he gets by me even if he
can get by me and get through the next
like maybe turn or two after he's gotten
by me it's pretty much game over so now
I have to hold him off until the end of
the race and he's just a better driver
so that's gonna be really hard so let's
talk about the rules real quick in
general in racing blockings not allowed
so as the leading driver you get one
move per turn and that's kind of like to
assert your line so you can't just like
you know swerve left and right to stop
someone from passing you that's that's
not allowed that's called blocking so
for the person trying to pass you can do
anything you want the only rules for you
apply like with you know sis ya have to
stay on track like so you can't exceed
the track limits and you have to pay
attention to the whole like who's ahead
at turn in but if if you're the chasing
car and you're ahead at turn in you have
that you have the turn and you probably
you're probably gonna pass that person
the other thing to note is like if
you're on the inside of the turn in your
head at turnin even if it like it is
your turn so that means in theory you
can push the other person basically off
track
obviously this rule gets superseded by
another rule like leave racing room but
it's honestly a really great area and
can get really close so here's a quick
example from earlier in the race and
this is not what the faster driver this
is still his dad is in the car right now
and we're coming up to turn 20 and he's
going for the past I personally think it
was pretty close but who knows and I'm
trying to get back on but nope he's
holding there and I'm literally like in
the grass and then I have no choice but
to get behind him so even if like even
if you think that you have that turn you
like part of your job is like like
nobody wants to hit anybody right so the
rules really only apply if there's
contact if there's not contact you can
do whatever you want so yeah so my job
as a driver here is to try to stay in
front of Russell and read what he's
telegraphing and kind of try to predict
what he's going to do because I only get
one
move to try to defend and you can see
here he tries to follow that faster car
cuz I needed to let that faster car by
it's a cup car definitely should let him
by
but then Russell tries to sneak by and
he actually gets by and now I know I
have no choice I have to get by him as
soon as possible but I get blocked in no
doubt about it
Russell knew I would get blocked by that
of the car but I'm just trying to hold
trying to hold trying to hold trying to
squeeze sort of get I'm a little bit
there I've got no option to go the
inside line and I'm still going he's
needed seized right next to me I get on
the throttle just a little sooner and
I've squeezed him out and yeah that was
really difficult in like yeah sometimes
the traffic works in your favor
sometimes it's a little against you but
that's the kind of stuff you guys start
paying attention to so yeah just just a
really close battle there and then there
I'm not really sure I think that guy's
going off to pit or something caught me
by surprise and there's Russell on my
tail again luckily it's a yellow flag so
I know he can't pass there but you have
to stay on throttle because he can pass
by the next turn unless that turn how to
yellow flag so yeah sometimes traffic's
gonna work against you but in this case
this is an example of trying to use
traffic to your advantage so I kind of
pegged this 997 here as someone I can
use to cover options so what you can do
is use them to block one of the options
for the person you know behind you so I
get over here I have no intention to
pass the nine on seven on the inside
they're all I'm trying to do is that 997
sort of blocks Russell to take the
outside I've locked the inside all set
same thing again here I'm just covering
it I didn't actually want to pass him
but then he goes a little wide and it's
kind of slow so then I decide okay I
have to pass him I can't just hang
behind him because otherwise Russell or
Carter's gonna pass him and me so I'm by
him and then Russell comes over and then
I decide you know what I lift and I
break really hard really early and
Russell has nowhere to go he can't get
over he gets too slow for that turn and
then I get right back in front of that
997 but the 997 is able to stay in front
of Russell because I basically just
parked it and turned one so that worked
out really well and since it's so hard
to pass in the esses I'm pretty
confident Russell's gonna get held up
all the way through here and sure enough
he does that was like perfection that
was probably my best use of traffic the
entire weekend eventually he does get by
that 997 but it takes him a while and it
gives me an opportunity because he's
heating up his tires a lot trying to get
he's working really hard to get by and
meanwhile I'm just kind of taking it
easy like my tires cool back down again
and so anyway yeah that was a was a
really cool moment for the weekend but
soon he's back on on my tail putting the
pressure on but yeah an awesome epic
fight
so yeah it was basically that for like
15 minutes straight that's the most
pressure I think I've ever been under
and it's like it's so hard not to mess
up and like in your mind you keep
thinking like especially like towards
the end we did like three extra laps and
so the whole time I'm like I'm you start
you you're you just started thinking
like man how bad would it be if I missed
up right here I've held him off for this
long yeah what if he gets by that would
be the story and you gotta like push
those thoughts out and so yeah you gotta
you guys just keep driving like these
perfect laps and do everything just
right so yeah that was a really cool
battle and after that you know he came
up and congratulated me and just said
like man I just tried everything I could
on you and it was just it was really
really cool and like that's the sort of
thing you'll just you never get at a
track day look at it when you just go to
a regular track day it's just you and
your car and like the lap time or
something there's not really much to it
whereas in a race there's just so much
more going on it's so much more
challenging that it's just something
totally different
I just thought racing would be like a
slight step up from a de but really
racing is like another level and
entirely so anyways that's my first
raised weekend just say incredible
experience I'm super thankful that I
could do it I learned so much including
just like how important it is to have a
team with you like again at a track days
just you and your car but like at a race
like you really need all these people
and like the engineers keeping the car
running had a coach that's like helping
me improve my driving and kind of like
keeping the team together really I mean
like we definitely would not have won
for sure the enduro without the coach
because I was ready to just say hey
let's just make sure we can finish this
race and the engineer like are the
engineers their goal is yeah keep the
car running let's do what we can to make
sure we can finish and so but as a team
your job is to try to win so anyway yeah
with with all these people coming
together it was just it was just such an
awesome experience that you know I knew
it was gonna be cool I just did not know
it was gonna be that cool so anyway
maybe I'll get to race sometime in the
future we'll see but I'm super stoked to
have had the opportunity to do it so
yeah if anybody wants
answer a racecar all right now anyway
back to our regularly scheduled
programming now this is a nine nine 7.2
Porsche Carrera S and today I'm gonna
give it a dog score